[Music]
my name is tin Yun and I'm a product
manager on the cloud AI team and today
I'm here to talk about a new product we
are launching for delivering highly
personalized shopping experiences on GCP
but before we begin I wanted to step
back and provide a little bit of context
what is so hard about delivering good
recommendations which is the the key
component of personalization well if you
think about the basic setup it involves
for a given user in a context that
they're interacting with you in
recommending an item from a long list of
potential items that you could show them
and there are challenges along each of
these major steps right so for users you
have cold-start users that you've never
seen before you have users who have
shifting habits so even if you have seen
them before they may not be behaving the
same way anymore and you also have the
sparse feedback problem they don't
actually interact with every one of your
products they only ever interact with a
few and frequently only the head items
then you have changing context they're
on different pages of your website
they're interacting with you from a
different device iOS or Android or
whatnot there's changing channel
sometimes they're in store sometime
there's on mobile versus desktop and
then there's changing location right
they might be signing in from different
geographies and finally items you might
have a new product launch so it's a cold
start item with no history so you don't
necessarily know how to recommend it you
have sparse labels so especially for the
tail items you might not have
significant signal on how people click
and purchase it and it's hard to
recommend and then for especially there
in the retail setting for a lot of your
products the most important information
is not necessarily in the clicks and
purchases but in the unstructured
metadata so for example the description
of a book or the image of a dress right
and in this situation with all these
different challenges you have to solve
all of them to deliver a good
recommendation which is actually really
difficult and by the way you have to do
this in a hundred milliseconds with up
to billions of items and billions of
users at least in the Google setting
so luckily here at Google we've been
able to accumulate years of experience
across multiple flagship properties on
how to make recommendations better
including with the latest deep learning
approaches so for example in search we
do search we do personalized search
ranking with YouTube we predict what
video you should watch next based on
your viewing history in Google Play we
predict what app you're likely to
install and so forth so here's an
example from YouTube now this was
published in The Verge so more than 70%
of the time people spend watching videos
on the site is now driven by YouTube's
algorithmic recommendations that's a
significant share so in light of this
both the challenges as well as the great
recommendations technology and
infrastructure we've built up at Google
we decided to provide all of this as a
managed service to enable retailers to
deliver state-of-the-art highly
personalized product recommendations to
their shoppers in real time and at scale
we call this product recommendations ai
which I'm proud to announce is in
limited beta as of yesterday the way it
works is we provide a fully managed
global scale service that basically
works out of the box and by managed
service I mean there's a whole slew of
problems that we solve on your behalf so
there's no need for you to think about
it so for example there's no need for
you to think about cleaning and priest
processing your ingest the data because
we'll do things like to duplicate your
user events filter bot traffic etc on
your behalf no need to think about
writing state-of-the-art machine
learning code keeping up with the latest
deep learning advances making sure that
your models cover your entire product
catalog and do so in low latency all
these are very challenging problems and
we take care of that for you essentially
cherry-picking the best of what is
coming out internally from the other
consumer facing teams at Google there's
no need for you to think about
maintaining resilient training pipelines
making sure that your pipelines run day
in and day out without failure no need
to think about addressing common biases
that can skew your recommender such as
popular items seasonality on sale items
as well as making sure that your
recommender properly recommends when it
hits cold start items or tail items no
need to think about replicate
your service across regions we do that
for you so wherever your shoppers are we
can serve it no need to think about
provisioning servers to handle spiky
traffic retailers in the room probably
know that you can have 3x or even 10x
spikes in terms of user traffic so no
need to think about it will automate
dealing with that for you no need to
think about building monitoring error
checking and learning systems as well as
relevant dashboards in so obviously this
is extremely important in case your
recommendation fails for some reason in
the pipeline will warn you and will also
enable you to check it and debug it in
your dashboard and then finally no need
for you to manage the latency
availability and cost for all of these
above components the way to think about
it is that not only are each of these
steps extremely difficult to deal with
but there are also potential points of
failure for your overall system so we
take care of all of that make it
resilient make it work make it best
practice and all you need to do is
ingest your product catalog and user
events and then from the predict API
retrieve and then display the
recommendation results and then you only
have to pay for the recommendations
served so all the underlying
infrastructure costs we take care of for
you and we bundle it in in terms of
recommendation options we provide a
comprehensive portfolio of choices
suited for the retail setting which you
can retrieve with just a simple predict
API call as I mentioned earlier so first
you can choose a recommendation type and
we have the primary types that are
available that are needed for a retail
website right for example recommended
for you which is based on your shopping
history what are you likely to click on
or buy next usually used on the homepage
other items you may like for
recommending relevant other relevant
items on the product detail page but
doing so in a personalized way based on
your shopping history frequently bought
together so suggesting complimentary
items to a current one that you're
already thinking of buying right as
opposed to a substitute item and then
shopping cart and registry expansion so
let's say you already have five items in
your cart what other items go with that
that cart next for each of these
recommendation placements you can define
your objective so whether you want to
optimize for engagement
or click-through rate at the time
conversion rate or revenue procession so
we could rewrite the options based on
the price for you and finally
fine-tuning results so you can do things
like filtering out of stock items
filtering duplicate items especially
useful if you have a large category with
many overlapping items filter by custom
tags that you provide turn
diversification on or off as well as
turn personalization on or off usually
personalization will achieve better
metrics but there might be unique
circumstances where you don't want to
personalize and as I mentioned earlier
as input to the recommender system we
take your product catalog as well as a
live stream of your user events and
because we're using the latest deep
learning architectures we put all of
your data to work every every last ounce
of it so for example in the product
catalog we not only use the history of
clicks and purchases for each of those
products but we also use the rich
metadata that's available in the catalog
you provide the name of the product the
description the categories etc all of
these things are used directly as inputs
in the neural net model to enable our
models to recommend better especially
for cold start items or tail items where
the only signal we have potentially is
from the metadata itself next we also
take a live feed of real-time user
events and we use every bit of it not
only just the aggregate clicks and
clicks and purchases but also the exact
sequence of user events down to what
happened in the last second in order to
in order to inform the recommender so
the exact sequence the event type of
each of the elements in the sequence the
ordering the distance between each of
the events all of these are used as
signal into our model as well as things
like the domain and device other custom
features you might provide for the the
event context ingesting this data is
easy as well so we have built in
integrations to enable easy data
ingestion from a large number of touch
points that you already have with Google
for example if you already send your
product catalog to the Google Shopping
team for your product for managing your
product listing ads then you can use the
same in
for recommendations AI similarly if you
already use Google tag manager for
ingesting user events from your website
then we do have a native tag integration
with Google tag manager that you can
turn on and of course if your historic
data is stored in Google Cloud storage
or bigquery we can ingest from there as
well in order to for example warm start
the recommender but of course if you
prefer more traditional options like a
back-end API or or a JavaScript snippet
we have those options available also and
of course none of this would matter if
we couldn't deliver results and I'm
proud to say that after working with a
number of pilot customers all over the
world delivering recommendations on
their full hundred percent production
ecommerce traffic we've been able to
prove our ability to deliver significant
lifts on key metrics key business
metrics that you care about as shown in
a B experiments controlled by our
customers versus their baseline
solutions so for example up to a 90
percent improvement in recommendation
driven click-through rate up to a 50
percent improvement in recommendation
driven revenue as well as up to a total
a five percent improvement in total
revenue per session I'm especially proud
of this last metric it looks small but
actually it's the biggest one because
typically a for the pilots that we've
worked with the pilot customers we
worked with recommendations tends to the
baseline tends to provide only a small
share of their total revenue something
like 10 percent we've even seen less
than 5 percent so if you can increase
the total revenue by up to 5 percent
that's actually a pretty significant
improvement and as a caveat these
metrics are meant to give you a sense of
the upper ranges of what we've been able
to achieve the upper ranges the full
range of actual results can vary
dramatically based on a lot of factors
such as the positioning of the
recommender on your website if you put
it at the very bottom of the page
obviously we're not going to impact all
the revenue that much no matter what the
number of products in the catalog the
more products you have the more likely
our recommender has room to do
innovative new things that it couldn't
do before but whether there are any data
integration issues and this is actually
the biggest the biggest issue that we've
come across when it comes to model
quality if people can't achieve the
results typically there
some kind of data integration issue
involved things like maybe the user
events are not being sent properly maybe
the product catalog is not being updated
regularly
maybe the predictions are not actually
being shown in the appropriate order all
of these are things that we've hit on a
regular basis in a/b experiments in the
middle of a B experiments so this is
probably the biggest category of things
to watch out for and finally of course
if you have a large data science team
that has already been working on
recommendations for many years likely
you won't see these kinds of results
across the board but I would I believe
that it would be great if you could test
it on individual locations that maybe
you haven't worked as hard on and then
it could still provide significant lift
for those so you can think about ways to
mix and match whatever is the best of
breed from in-house as well as from us
that's one of the reasons why we decided
to price per prediction so you can do
that kind of thing
and now I'd like to show you a demo of
our dashboard from which you can monitor
the performance of your recommender as
well as the health of your data
integrations so here's what the
dashboard looks like you can manage you
can monitor your overall recommender
performance as well as the performance
so on metrics that you care about for
system-wide like total revenue
recommender and gauge revenue and so
forth as well as the performance of
individual recommendation placements so
for example the performance of your
homepage we can take on that dig in on
that and see how it's doing
similarly you can look at the health of
your data integration so you can see how
how your integration is doing so for
example you can see whether the total
number of products looks correct whether
the right number of products is in stock
sometimes people accidentally turn out
of stock on and then forgot to forget to
turn it back in stock so we put this
here you can make sure that your product
catalog is up-to-date and you can also
check the status of your user event in
integration so we've actually come
across situations where even one team
manages the recommender and another team
manages the broader like website
experience and that team will
accidentally delete the
a pixel of the team that's doing the
recommender so you would see stuff like
that where there's a massive user event
drop here from this dashboard and a
common problem we also see is that
people send product IDs in their user
events that actually are not in the
product catalog itself so we help you
track that as well because obviously if
you send us a Product ID that doesn't
exist in the product catalog then we
can't do anything with it right so you
can track that here as well and then
we're also one of the benefits of being
part of Google cloud the platform is
that there are all sorts of other
systems for maintaining production
systems that we can be natively
integrated to so for example you can
check your API metrics here people
especially care about the latency and
the error rate of their predict method
in terms of retrieving recommendations
so you can monitor that here so just I'm
just going to turn on the just set it to
the filter to the predict API method and
you can see the the total traffic the
errors that are happening the latency of
these of these calls so obviously a lot
of you want to keep the recommender at
the 95th percentile within 150
milliseconds just to make sure it's a
highly dynamic experience so we'll help
you you can check that at any time as
well as like more detailed latency view
here next you can go over individual
errors that you've hit so this is also a
common issue where people send send poor
data so we can so we can allow you to
deep dive on what the errors are and
finally one of the big things in terms
of making sure that recommender is
making money for you day in and day out
is you have to actually make sure it's
working on a daily basis but you don't
want to look at the dashboard every
single day right so if you want to avoid
that you can also set up alerting
so here for example in this in this demo
project we've set up an alert for when
put the note the predict errors is above
zero so if there's ever some kind of
system problem that causes the pipeline
to break
you can be alerted without Ewing at you
having to look at the dashboard every
day so all sorts of functionality to
ensure that your recommender is making
money for you day in and day out so on
top of having state-of-the-art models
and recommendation techniques if we go
back to the slides and finally since
these questions always get asked I
wanted to let you know up front that you
can rest easy so your data isn't used
for any other Google customer or Google
product just belongs to you and sits
inside your project your data isn't
mixed with that of other Google
customers we don't mix all the user
events together and create one master
model there's one model per customer
that we were trained on a daily basis
you always can delete your data and
models at any time this is a commonly
asked question and finally we support
gdpr compliance and now I would like to
introduce Robert and Dan from emag one
of the largest online retailers in
Eastern Europe and whom we are honored
to have as one of our pilot customers
hello everyone my name is Robert Nicolai
and I am targeting product owner at emag
and this is the envelop of one of our
best engineers we are part of Emacs
targeting team and today we are going to
speak about recommendations and our
experience with Google recommendation ca
so this is what I've learned in the past
five years working in the targeting
business nobody wants to be sorry I'm
just joking
nobody wants to shop alone we can say
that today the internet is about
personalization we have social media
apps news feeds or streaming platforms
that are providing experiences based on
user interest and also ecommerce
platforms are trying to adapt to this
trend as Tizen has mentioned is not an
easy job but this is our job we need to
understand the customers needs and to
provide the personalized shopping
experience for each one of our users
first of all a few things about who here
emag it's a Romanian unicorn the company
was founded in 2001 and was valuated at
over 1 billion dollars in 2018 we are an
organization which is
in the explain expanding in the region
aiming to become the largest online
retailer in this part of Europe today he
maggots the largest place the largest
marketplace in Romania it is a top
online retailer in Bulgaria and Hungary
and is also present in Poland we have
over 4,000 talented people that work
every day to make our customers lives
better by saving them time and money at
emag we use technology and innovation to
facilitate the best online shopping
experience so the Google Cloud
invitation to test the new
recommendation I was exactly what we
need for our recommendation project Emax
goal is to deliver the most friendly and
helpful shopping experience by offering
a wide range of products and categories
services that are always updated biased
based on the client's needs our team the
targeting team is responsible for
developing the internal recommendation
engine managing how our platforms adapt
and react to each user through
pasteurised content you know
recommendation widgets or in other areas
why is this important because more than
20% of our daily orders are from
recommendations now my colleague Dan
will present our will present our rec
app or Alfred thanks Robert
as Robert already mentioned our main aim
is to create an unique recomm unique
experience for each mark user in order
to do this we created a personal
assistant who will know customers
preferences and the habits - his name is
alfred alfred is a max recommendation up
and he's pretty busy only on a macro he
should provide over 1 billion unique
recommendations per month in order to do
this we're using internal or third-party
recommendation algorithm to generate
recommendations which will be shown in
widgets in order to provide it in
customers touch point of course Alfred
has some service responsibilities some
ezeli's for example he knows what he
should deliver
recommend more than 99% of success
recommendations and he has only 250
milliseconds to provide best
recommendations for each customer alfred
knows that he must deliver an average of
seven thousand requests per seconds on
all four platters mentioned above in
addition to this he should provide them
separately for desktop site mobile site
mobile app and targeting application in
order to do all this job offer need some
resources which are represented by its
infrastructure he has 16 web server
machines 8 worker machines 20 database
machines of 4 different types and 9 q
machines of 2 different types we should
agree it's a great amount of resources
used for Alfred days by this business
but it's not all where is the day in the
year when everyone wants to shop faster
and to get perfectly fitted products for
them we're speaking about Black Friday
in this day Alfred knows but he must
roll up his sleeves and providin more
than 20,000 requests per seconds with a
maximum error rate of 1% in order to
ensure fees we need to scale his
resources up to 3 times as we have
mentioned allocate some friends some
third party recommendation engines and
his new best friend is recommendations
AI for us it took only 5 working days to
teach Alfred to speak with his new
friend in just 7 days we had the first
model life continuing to improve it and
testing it in our site we have
configured Google tag manager to send
user events to recommendations AI
freeing Alfred from doing this job also
our app sends catalog item updates
ensuring the real-time stock updates in
recommendations as a result in first
month you can have your first model live
as we had one important to mention here
we made two integrations one of PHP and
one if golang it is it was very simple
now Robert will show us some more
numbers so the first recommendation a
scenario tested was other items you may
like only Mac the best interaction with
the recommendations is on the product
page on the first widget so we have
tested other items you may like versus
our own scenario that we have privileges
used for disposition related items a
content-based filtering algorithm what
about the results we had an important
increase in to click through rate 26%
direct driven conversion rate was
boosted with 32 percent and direct
revenue drink sorry
and the Reg driven revenue was boosted
with 40 percent also we have noticed
significant 5% increase in total revenue
per session pretty cool not so this is
not all we have also tested the frequent
repo together scenario this time the the
widget is lower on the page under state
composition and it usually contains
cross-selling product recommendations
based on manual rules created by our
commercial department this time the
results was even better we have 100%
increased in regular even click-through
rate and 100 at 80% to rec given
conversion rate increase also we have
180 percent directive on revenue boost
we have also one percent to increase in
total revenue per session sorry
as you can see the difference are very
significant and we can definitely say
that there I performed better than the
manual rules so then was next
as a result of Alfred integration of
recommendations AI we can freed more
than 25% of each previously used
infrastructure resources yeah that one
but was big average error rate of
recommendations I scenarios is lower
than 0.001 percent and it's great for us
now the integration of a new scenarios
requires only model training for Alfred
everything can be done in its UI what
comes next for often in his new friend
from our point of view its integration
of a new scenarios it's a be testing the
existing implementations and adding
recommendations a scenarios in homepage
catechol targeting emails and others we
are looking forward to is or
recommendations a available scenarios
went to Frank Tinian and well
recommendations a team for this
opportunity thank you all right thanks
guys for that great story
and now being the PM for this product
naturally I've looked closely at the
retail tech space and I know there's so
much more to delivering an end-to-end
magical shopping experience than just
great machine learning algorithms so
here at Cloud a I we know we can't do
everything ourselves and we don't want
to do everything ourselves
so wherever there are great GCP partners
that we can work with that is definitely
our preferred route and with that I'd
like to introduce Steve from Sur Tona
which recently joined forces with Kibo
to deliver an industry-leading
unified cloud commerce platform with
personalization at his core and whom we
are proud to have as a partner I'm Steve
quant I'm the principal architect at
certo certo has been doing
personalization for almost 15 years now
have a pretty good product base just
recently joining with Kibo and with that
mmm green button area with that
integration now we're able to add full
stack solutions to our capabilities as a
combined company we have cart and
check-out capabilities order management
point mobile point of commerce the
product search and discovery content
management product recommendations
personalized email and remarketing and
real-time experience management the
experience management's across the
multiple platforms personalization at
all the different endpoints as Tinian
was saying saying earlier
recommendations aren't necessarily that
easy there's a lot more than just the
recommendations we've integrated with
the recommendation ai but there's also
the real-time tag management we provide
test and optimization
do you have reporting
we have been integrated with the big
data analytics using bigquery to provide
our customers their data and able to
share our data with them with
recommendations there's managing the
site but there's also managing the
customer experience when you have a site
and they have their marketing people
responsible for what they're doing it
starts with the machine machine
algorithms but having boost and bury
business rules have being able to
present being able to integrate your
visitor profile being able to integrate
your product context there's a lot more
than just the AI and with the cert ona
platform and the Kibo products we're
able to integrate these touch points and
provide a end-to-end experience for
customer sites
how it all works is starting with the
online data and offline data integrating
that together we session eyes your data
for reporting and sharing internally
with our customers send that data both
as Tinian said earlier your previous
session batch data as well as your
current live stream integrating
integrating customer data catalog data
into the Google cloud platform getting
the recommendations back presenting it
to the site and back all the way to the
customer touch point whether that's
their website product or email
recommendations remarketing
recommendations in-store recommendations
this is an example of our experienced
manager this is our user interface into
our platform when you're integrating
with the Google or the Cir Tona platform
the Google recommendations are just
another strategy for how you present
products along with our standard set you
just select the Google recommendations
and one of the things that Google
provides on top of this is there's a lot
of sometimes marketing managers want to
introduce their own business rules they
want to have certain slots that they
want to target stuff that isn't
necessarily bought together or some
other strategy that's on the page where
they want to highlight particular items
and they're also wanting to do a/b
testing all of that comes out of the box
with the Cir tone of recommendation
package and integrating with the Google
ai is one of the tools that we see going
forward that is going to allow us to
scale even better and take advantage of
current technology in the recommendation
modeling another product that we see has
a huge future with us is the data
science platform bigquery able to easily
recommend integrate our data with our
customers data and allow for a richer
product experience and also for visual
of visualization and you know digging
deeper into the product set that's
available with the working with Google
why Google definitely there was a
strategic alignment with customers we
share a lot of their customers a lot of
our customers are already in the Google
platform they're you know they have the
state-of-the-art AI it's an easy
integration
we integrated with their web api and
very simple to use they have definitely
state-of-the-art infrastructure
scalability issues aren't an issue being
able to have global reach our customers
are distributed all over the world to
get a an edge that's close to their
where they need that presence is
definitely something that Google has for
us and also working with great people
here at Google
and back to Jinyoung thank you thank you
Steve for sharing that great
introduction to our partnership and now
in closing please note that we are in
limited beta right now so because we've
had significant interest we're current
we currently only have a limited number
of spots but if you're interested please
contact your Google Account Manager to
get on the waiting list and we'll try to
get started ramping you up as soon as we
can
[Music]